Now that we understand how
hardware-supported protection levels can
be used, we can start explaining how
virtualization techniques can be
developed that achieved our goal to
efficiently at near native speeds
allow execution of virtual machines
on top of these basically
identical virtual platforms.
First, guest instructions are executed
directly by the hardware.
That's important thing to know.
The virtual machine
monitor does not interfere
with every single instruction that is
issued by the guest operating system, or
its applications for that matter.
What this means is that just like the OS
doesn't interfere on every single
instruction and memory access, here the
hypervisor does not interpose itself on
every single operation and every single
memory access performed by the guest.
As long as the guest
operating system and
its applications operate within
the resources that were allocated
to them by the hypervisor,
then everything is safe.
The instructions in those cases
will operate at hardware speeds and
this will lead to efficiency of
the virtualization solution.
Whenever a privileged instruction gets
accessed, then the processor causes
a trap, and control is automatically
switched to the most privileged level,
so to the hypervisor.
At this point the hypervisor can
determine whether the operation is to
be an allowed or not.
If the operation is an illegal
operation and it shouldn't be allowed,
then the hypervisor can perform some
action like to terminate the VM.
If the operation is, should be allowed,
however, it's a legal operation,
in that case, the hypervisor should
perform the necessary emulation so
that the guest operating system is
under the impression that it actually
does have control over the hardware.
So from the guest perspective, it should
seem as if the hardware did exactly what
it was expected to do
given the instruction.
In reality, however,
it was the hypervisor that intervened,
that potentially executed
slightly different set of operations
in order to achieve that emulation.
This trap-and-emulate mechanism is
a key method in which virtualization
solutions rely in order to achieve
efficient CPU virtualization.